-Guys, before we go on, I'd like
to take a moment to thank
some of our sponsors
for tonight's show.
They don't always fit
in the commercial breaks,
and we want to make sure that we
mention all of them.
So, it's time for
"Tonight Show Sponsors."
Here we go.
-♪ Tonight show sponsors ♪
♪ Tonight show sponsors ♪
[ Applause ]
-AMC Theaters.
You thought we'd clean
the floors
in the last year and a half?
Think again.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Sunglass Hut.
Your second favorite "Hut"-based
establishment.
[ Laughter and applause
The Olympics.
Well, well, well,
look who's finally
signing up for Peacock.
[ Cheers and applause ]
White Claw.
Find out what you did tonight
on TikTok tomorrow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Little Caesars.
If we can make a pizza
for you in five minutes,
maybe question
what's going on here.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Toblerone.
Why yes, I was just at
an airport duty-free store.
Why do you ask?
[ Laughter and applause ]
The Hallmark Channel.
We know it's July,
but somebody's gotta
fall in love
with Santa Claus.
[ Applause ]
Johnson & Johnson.
Fine, okay, we'll just stick
to baby shampoo from now on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Pandora.
Enjoy having your favorite music
interrupted
by an incredibly loud ad
for Tide!
[ Applause ]
MTV.
Yes, we still think
"Ridiculousness"
is going to take off.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And finally, Costco.
You'll die before you finish
this tub of ketchup.
[ Laughter ]
That's all
for "Tonight Show Sponsors."